>>Pamela: One of the most challenging
things for children to do is
to bring themselves into
a state of calm.
Mindfulness contributes to a
child's ability to self-regulate
and bring themselves into
a calm state for learning.
>>Lindsey: When students come
from the dining hall after lunch,
we do a very short guided
mindfulness practice.
We're ready to transition from the
energy of lunch into a different kind
of energy for our humanities.
It's a way for students to
sort of recenter themselves,
check in with their brains
and their hearts
and their bodies, and
see where they're at.
>>Okay, kiddos. We're
going to get started
Taking a big breath in. And
letting it out with a little noise.
>>I always start with a
couple kind of big breaths.
>>Another big one in.
>>Here at our school, we're really
aware of the vast variety of needs
that students can have, whether
they're academic needs, social needs,
emotional needs, behavioral
needs, or physical needs.
>>Our eyes are going closed.
If that doesn't feel good,
we're looking down or covering our eyes.
>>I never require kids
to close their eyes,
because that can feel really unsettling.
We talk about looking into the palms
of their hands or they're looking
into the seam on their sneakers,
whatever works for them.
>>We are here. We are safe.
>>I have a few students who can
sit cross-legged for an hour
on end, it would be totally fine.
I have other kids that, for their
bodies, that's incredibly challenging.
So being seated in a chair or at
a wall, so they have something
to lean into, is really helpful.
The kids who had stuffed animals
needed those, either for sort
of like a sensory tactile input or
a soothing comfort sort of input.
So there's no judgment around it,
but there's a level of awareness
so they can do what they need to do.
>>Three, two, one.
>>And then, I always
count down at the end.
>>Bring yourself back to this room.
Eyes open. Eyes open.
>>A few kids will fall asleep,
and they need to be woken up.
>>All right. Silent hands for shares.
>>I do like to build in
reflections as often as possible.
>>Student: When I was
in the dining hall,
my heart was going beep,
beep, beep, beep.
>>Student: But now, when
we did mindfulness,
my heart feels so nice and calm.
>>Student: We do mindfulness
because-- tell them.
>>Student: We do mindfulness because
during lunch, it gets a little crazy.
And so, when we go upstairs, we calm
down so we can transfer to writing.
>>Pamela: Very often, practices like
mindfulness enable children to get
that inner calm again after they've had
a stressful experience in a classroom,
in a lunchroom, in the hallway.
>>Lindsey: Who can tell me what it
means for a text to be a fiction text?
>>Student: Fiction is when it's not
real and non-fiction is when it is real.
>>Lindsey: Nice.
>>The impact of the mindfulness
practice is really this general sense
of them being more comfortable
and confident with themselves
and they're varying needs and decreases
in anxiety around academic work.
>>Double kiss for your
brain. Amazing job.